try to see if we can get those
transferred over for him to address but
if you're on Zoom please put those into
the Q a
and in the meantime
we're just about that time so let's get
started
and uh welcome everyone to this webinar
and why you should get a general
management certification
in 2023 from IIM indoor
as I mentioned uh we're here with
Professor moriani who will um
take us through a little bit about the
program before I
tell you some of the other details We'll
be asking a couple of questions along
the way I will also talk about what
executive management is what this
program offers how it develops your
skills and I'll take you through
enrollment steps and we'll have a brief
q a uh both at the beginning and at the
end obvious additional questions come up
but right now I'd like Professor Mariani
to introduce himself as the associate
professor mark
hi hello everyone welcome to this
webinar we have an objective that we
would like to talk in detail about this
particular program what are its
objective uh so that you can take a much
more informed decision whether this is a
program which suits to you or possibly
you would also like to answer in case if
you have any queries about the program
structure so uh being a Prof my basic
idea here would be to talk about
academics parts of the questions or
doubts which you have to solve that out
as the slide says uh let me introduce
myself hi my name is Manoj motyani I
work with I am Indo for last 10 years
and I am currently associate prop in the
marketing area before coming to I am
indoor I completed my PhD from I am
Ahmedabad before that I worked in
industry for a brief period of time at
Aditya group as well as at godrej
consumer private limited as a scholar I
have published few papers and
possibility of the reports which are
available in both media and possibility
research portrait and we do a small
amount of Consulting work for various
companies as well as possibly some ngos
to work with my research interests as a
professor is in the field of Sales
Management Service marketing neural
marketing these would be few areas in
which I am more interested in terms of
doing my research Consulting and
training
to explain you about I am indoor I am
indoor was established in 1996 so we in
some sense are the second Generations I
am which got started up by government of
India we have two campuses one main
campus which is in I am indoor where we
actually host all our programs which
include pgp IPM epgp all full-time
programs which are run from I am indoor
green Campus we also have another
auxiliary campus in Mumbai its main
target is to possibly have the cater
management development programs and also
we run our pgpmx program which is
basically a full-time two years program
but the classes only happen in weekend
and given you have some 5-10 years of
experience you are eligible for this
particular aspect
now as you might be aware that I am
indoor is ranked as one of the premium
Institute in this country and we have
been continuously ranked as a top B
school both in India and abroad for
example in narf ranking our rank is
seven our Global MBA ranks 25th in the
Asia I'm just so sorry I'll just give
the answers of all the questions you're
putting on the chat uh just after
finishing this we have a proper q a
route we are also being accredited by AC
ABS Amba as well as equal certification
which is called triple crop so in India
we have this only second Institute which
has the Triple Crown in this country
which is the three different
certifications which are a Hallmark of
the quality of the education which I am
in will provide now when we talk about
this specific program
this is executive certificate program in
general management its duration would be
six months and it exits five to ten
hours per week of work
the idea for this particular program was
the people who want to uh have some sort
of an exposure for the general
Management program and obviously it's
not feasible for them to attend any
full-time programs possibly they would
be the one who would be most benefited
out of it we have a comprehensive
curriculum which is aligned to the
industry in terms of learning path so
whatever the core structure which has
been selected is assuming that we will
have a courses right from The Beginner's
level to possibly a little bit of an
advanced debit so that you can cover the
entire spectrum and it is assumed you
have work experience so many of the
organization related things you guys
would be able to use them to create the
most out of this particular program
there will be a Hands-On projects for
practical experience one of that we will
discuss later would be the Capstone
project you will have an online live
virtual classroom classes apart from the
asynchronous classes so that you will
have a flexibility in terms of
completing this course based on your
time frame as many of the lectures are
asynchronous that means you will see the
recording and plus just to strengthen
the aspect of what we have covered we'll
also have a live classes where the
instructors would come and have an
interaction with you related to the
curriculum which they have covered which
gives you a little bit of flexibility in
terms of completing this course so after
completing this course you will be
getting a certificate from I am indoor
which will be uh classifying you that
you have completed your executive
program here and you will get a status
of I am indoor alumni executor right so
that would be the status which you will
be getting there will be a three days
campus immersion program for which there
is an additional cost so that means you
can come to the campus experience it
there will be also classes uh which will
be conducted in those three days if you
don't attain that still if you are able
to complete the other requirement you
would be able to get your certificate of
completion
great
now let me talk about the structure and
design of this particular program so
we'll start with the orientation
sessions which basically talk about what
we'll be covering in this particular
course what would be the main idea basic
processing of how your classes will be
conducting the test which you have to
pass with that we'll start with the
smaller module which will be talking
about the Foundations of Management then
we briefly go toward understanding the
economic side of business accounting
then trying to go towards a more
specialized functional courses like
operation management supply chain
marketing management human resource then
talking about something which is much
more relevant possibly even at a senior
level which would be in the field of
business analytics management and
Leadership strategy design thinking
digital disruption and Innovation and
then there will be a Capstone project so
in the Capstone project what is this
supposed to do is we'll be requesting
you to pick up a live problem a
functional problem from your company on
which you would be working and then at
the end of the course you have to
present this particular problem how you
will able to tackle it what were some
things which you were able to do with it
which would be also a part of your
evaluation and it gives a complete
feedback loop system completed that you
after understanding about the basics of
the courses you are able to execute them
to solve the real life problems so that
is how possibly this particular program
would like to structure
all right so at this point we would like
to take some of your questions and I'm
going to look both in the chat in the Q
a starting with the Q a
um
we had a question from a user who wants
to know uh if you could compare the
executive postgraduate certificate
program in management executive
postgraduate management
e
yeah okay
let me explain you the difference
between these three different types of
operating when we talk about pgpmx
course or epgp course they are degree
courses which are offered by I am indoor
so if you have become a part of a epgp
program you have to stay in the campus
for one year complete all the course
requirement and at the end of the course
you get a one year MBA degree when we
talk about pgp MX it is for the people
who have a lot of work experience they
will be basically doing live classes in
Mumbai campus on the weekend days this
process they will continue for two years
after which they will be completing
their degree which will be talking about
pgp mxdb compared to these two programs
when you talk about the general
Management program its duration is six
months so and it offers you a
certificate not a degree which is a
little different you can understand the
technical difference between these two
things second obviously in pgp MX and
epdp programs all the classes are on
campus live classes compared to this we
have Asian Plus classes as well as
simple as classes so in terms of both
the content it's execution and the final
outcome these three programs have a very
different types of audience in mind
thank you
um Amit asks if if he has his MBA from
Pune University
in 15 years of experience uh is this an
appropriate program for him or would you
um recommend something else okay so see
just by having the line that you have a
15 years of experience in MBA it becomes
very difficult for me to give you a
ready-made solution but let me explain
you possibly what this program can do
for you and possibly what this program
won't be able to do for you see if you
have a 15 years of experience and you
are looking for a refresher in the sense
you want to refresh about the basic
concepts which are there in the
management and possibly upgrade yourself
in terms of what has happened in 15
years in terms of the management
principle that might be a great course
for you in case if you are looking for a
degree program possibly this is not the
right place to get a degree program or
possibly if your objective is that you
are looking for a Senior Management
specific roles right again this program
is are talking about specialization in a
very specific thing for example there
are programs which are very very
specific only in terms of leadership or
data Sciences this program is actually
not trying to achieve that so depending
upon what exactly you are seeking for
this program might be good for you or
possibly this my program might not be a
right fit for you
thank you
um we have a question from someone in
Malaysia if the certificate is
recognized there
okay when we talk about certificates
recognization I'm not sure about what
are the some specific requirements in
Malaysia generally when you go to other
countries Whenever there is a degree
when you claim there is a degree it has
to be approved from that particular
government because this is not a degree
program if you're looking at as a
diploma programmer certificate program I
think it might be considered as a degree
not a degree program but a certificate
program by the Malaysian government but
because it is decided by that particular
country I think we would like to check
it before you we give you a very very
strong response whether it will be
recognized in some sense you thank you
um
shamblavi has a
asked if this is for undergraduate
students and if you could go over some
of them believe this program is not for
undergrad students right basically the
idea is you would have already completed
your undergrad so this is not a program
that you're currently in the first year
of your undergrad and you are trying to
do this program the purpose of this
program is not for undergrad
we have a couple of questions about
price and I will talk about that a
little bit later in the webinar
um so please stay on board for that
um
and someone asked if the certificate
would be physical and not digital
and I believe we issue a digital
certificate do you know uh for sure the
answer to that Professor we gave a
digital certificate but there will be a
QR code right which talks about its
uniqueness
okay and which will help you to
recognize that who has been
uh given that anshita this is not a
forum where I can give you our tips for
the cat exam so firstly this is a wrong
place to ask that question
I'm going through the chat now to see if
there is this course also available for
us students
this program is available for all
students for all the countries because
it's a online program but you need to
see whether this time would get
synchronized with you or whether it
meets your requirement
and you'd be able to check the website
to find out but a general recommendation
which I'll make later is to contact us
uh through our email address to talk to
a learning consultant um
three days campus immersion
these is valid victories how many
planned in these three days or any time
uh know the valedictory ceremony will
happen on the three days of the campus
visit only okay and as you mentioned the
course requires work experience that was
one of the questions here
so you do have to come into this as a
working professional is that correct yes
okay I think that covers all of the
questions let me see if anything else is
come in know that you have a time limit
professor
do you have to answer yeah I'll surely
wait in case if anyone has a cushion a
totally like to answer that
okay and uh so we have a question if the
program is benefit beneficial from
someone who wants to Pivot out of the
education sector into the corporate
sector
okay
okay so please understand if you are
from education sector I I don't know at
which level you are whether you're a
school teacher or working possibly in a
college so depending upon the graduation
degrees which you have all the post
graduation degree which you have after
which you have got into academics as a
career maybe this General Management
program will help you to get a general
idea about how management functions
right so at some roles it might be
benefited but I'll be very honest with
you that this is not a degree program so
please understand after that you will
also have to work as they will be
providing you an opportunity to upload
your CVS on in terms of job but you need
to start your first step on your own to
build your management career thank you
um
we have an attendee who was able to join
late uh I want to assure everyone that
we will be sending an email after this
session uh get it in the next day or two
with a link to the recording of the
session so you'll be able to review this
um we had
we have two more questions I think yeah
I think so sneha says can we do the can
you do the course uh if you're preparing
for MBA entrance
my suggestion would be if you're
preparing for an MBA entrance this
program might not be directly beneficial
for you in any way to prepare for a MBA
because if you go in your MBA possibly
they have a very different co-curriculum
right so if you are looking for thinking
in terms of benefits for your MBA I
think then that's not a right way to
pick up the choice uh because in case if
you're doing MB it's a totally different
path but suppose you are someone who is
planning to learn about management
because it will be useful for your
current job or possibly in terms of the
career opportunities which are looking
this might be a useful course for you
thank you we have a question from a data
scientist who wants to move up into
management
um beyond the
analytical role in is this a good course
for that
so if you're a data scientist and you
think that maybe in your organization it
is required that you should have an
awareness about General management
concept for example you might be very
good in terms of doing a cluster
analysis right but possibly you are also
running it for the marketing department
to help them with the segmentation
problem in this program you will
understand exactly what is the things
which about which they were looking for
a Solutions so if your knowledge about
General management increase I think it
might be beneficial because you will get
a much better perspective about what
exactly you are doing in terms of
crunching those numbers so it might be
useful for you to move up the ladder
because you will have a apart from
technical expertise uh idea about
General management okay
and Professor you'd like to look through
the
questions in the Q a and pick the ones
that uh most appeal to you because
I think there's
a few down here there's one about
opportunities
no go ahead no you go ahead so I'll just
go in the reverse chronicle order
whether it will be useful for project
management sector again a Raj project
management sector itself is a huge
sector if you are someone who is in a
domain specific job related to project
management and you would like to get an
exposure and if to understand how the
general management work how these inter
departments work and possibly this
program would be very suitable for you
to get a general idea about how possibly
the organization work
as a career this okay let me answer I
think one more question has come
uh
is this program turned as EPG and
programming this epgn program have one
year duration of this program okay
please understand this is a executive
program this is not a degree granting
program so the program which you are
referring to which is called epgp
program that's a degree granting program
which is one year of duration which
happens in campus so this is not exactly
that one year program which we have
divided into two pieces the program
which you are talking about is a very
separate program compared to our epgp
program which is a residential program
which finally result into a degree
so it's very different in terms of
content and possibly its delivery and
the final outcome
I can ask a question about exams and the
process of uh assessments and tests on
this in this program uh can you mention
a little bit about that
sure so with every module when you would
be covering a module there will be an
exam which is basically McQ most of the
time there will be an McQ exam which is
there you have to give that exam and
score a suitable marks so that we get an
assurance that you were able to
understand that particular subject once
you have cleared all these exams there's
a Capstone project in a Capstone project
as I stated we will request you to
identify one problem from your
organization which is related to a
specific domain you will be doing an
industry analysis plus obviously in this
course there are domain specific modules
so you'll be also getting some insight
from the domain specific module which
should be covered and it is expected
that you will use that input to come up
with a report some sort of a
presentation which would be presenting
to us in terms of how you are able to
approach to that specific problem that
would be considered as your Capstone
project
okay and I think the last question
because I know you you have the time
limit is it from shootout uh who says
will the course cover the latest tools
and techniques in general management
okay when we talk about course covering
the latest tools and techniques see the
idea of these particular courses is
there will be a mix-up whenever suppose
if I'm trying to teach your marketing
I'll explain you from where the subject
has evolved eventually what are some new
things which are happening in this
particular subject even when you look
into the structure of this course so
being in the management field for last
now close to 15 18 years if I can say
that safely there were many topics which
in my possibly time of graduation were
not heard of for example design thinking
digital disruption the course is trying
its level best to update itself with the
latest happening in terms of management
and that has been aligned in this
particular program to make sure that it
is most relevant for the participants
wonderful thank you Professor um
and I think that is all the time we have
for questions for this part of the
presentation
and I want to thank you for being here
with us today great thank you thank you
Switzer and thank you to all the
participants for taking out time for
this particular webinar right and I want
to invite everyone to stay with us
please as I describe the program's other
details including the pricing
how to enroll so let's move on
I'm going to talk a little bit about
General management
some of the questions had an issue about
that but this is one of the reasons why
it's important to understand General
management and understanding in the
context of digital technology also
because of the digital Transformations
uh world has undergone especially in the
last several years
during the pandemic during the lockdowns
when many of us were asked to do work
from home many of the businesses we use
went to no contact methods when most
when more of Our Lives moved on to our
mobile devices
so
transformation in businesses abuse
fundamentally
profound and
we need as managers to understand
digital technology and its applications
and in the context of General management
how all of this works in the context of
all the functions of the business so as
you saw in the
curriculum
covers things like business analytics
that covers things like Supply Chain
management which has become
more top of Mind than some years so that
you understand the context of applying
all the skills in the holistic way and
we talk about
all of these types of
skills General management economics
accounting
financial management and then
understanding operations and supply
chain understanding marketing and Human
Resource Management
leadership skills of a manager the
Analytics
strategic in the design thinking and
digital disruption skills so
this gives you a holistic and
well-rounded
background
that opens up a number of different
career paths As you move up in
management you can department manager at
the division manager to a functional
area director general manager
up into the executive officers and then
finally into the c-suite as you gain
more experience over the years but
starting with this Foundation this gives
you a
opening into that path
so I would like to ask a poll of our
audience and if you're on the streaming
service you can put a b c d into your
comments and what this poll asks is what
has prevented you from doing a
certification of this type
up until now
it's open
for about another 15 seconds
I'll check one thing so
bear with me if your screen blanks for a
second
okay
and here is the answer to the poll
and so that the main
concerns for this audience are finding a
comprehensive curriculum in a program
this type
finding time in your work schedule to
accomplish it and getting the Practical
exposure to
be able to show off your new skills
so
we've talked about the curriculum and
the comprehensive curriculum I want to
go I think
into the
people who will be running the program
for you
uh you met professor matiani and
Professor Dash professor ostogi
professor
kajar
professor bilor professor Boston
Professor koduanio are all
um
faculty at IIM indoor and different
Specialties so different modules will be
conducted under the direction of these
different professors As you move through
the program you'll encounter experts
in each of the different areas as you
transition from one topic to the next so
it's a broad range program with a broad
base of Faculty Talent behind it
the prerequisites are that you must have
a bachelor's degree
so we cannot take unfortunately under
people still working on their degrees
for people with just a diploma you must
have two or more years of work
experience
um this is so that you have the context
and the uh environment in which to use
and practice the new skills that you're
gaining
and so that you have the
basic background to be able to
associate what you're learning to your
experience
you can come from any business
background or industry sector so the one
of the questions I saw earlier asked
about whether this is applicable in all
Industries and
the nature of this program is that it is
generally applicable you may learn
things
that don't specifically apply in your
business or that you think don't apply
for example you might not think that
supply chain applies to a digital based
business
providing software as a service for
example but you will get to see the new
connections that you hadn't thought of
before
so with this I would like to ask
how many years of experience do people
currently have
and we'll see who in our audience
be eligible for the program
leave this open for another
10 seconds
I will close the poll at five four three
two one
and I'll share the result
so about
looking here about 40 percent I think of
our audience
have more than five five years of
experience
or more than three years of experience
for the people who are in the zero to
three category
if you're just at the cusp
you want to time your entry if you're at
the three-year level you're eligible
uh folks who are here as undergrad
students
um you'll want to keep this in mind for
the future so
on now to
how the program prepares you and I'll
describe to you the learning environment
is completely digital
you have a learning management system
that allows you to manage your
curriculum to see all of the modules of
the program
and see the sequence that you will
follow
program is built in a way that you
follow that sequence fairly strictly
because of the fact that you'll be
taking live classes
and so it will be necessary to keep in
the sequence in order to make sure that
you're getting advantage of the classes
associated with the module and in each
module you'll be uh given the
information about how many of the live
classes you must attend
in order to complete the course and how
many of the
self-study modules uh and exercises
module and assessments and projects you
have to do
so each module unlocks access to the one
following
and
as each one completes you get a mini
certificate for that module that allows
you to move to the next one it's all
done again on the digital platform so
your classes are presented to you online
live ones the asynchronously recorded
ones you have access to pre-recorded
video material for review and
preparation before the live classes and
you also have a platform on which you do
your case studies your projects and your
tests and assessments on the same
digital platform so all of it is
available to you on any device that has
a web browser of course we recommend you
use a laptop or desktop for most of the
coursework but you can access much of
the material especially video recordings
on your mobile device
and it's available platforms available
24 7. so outside of the scheduled live
classes you can do the work at any time
that you have time in your week in your
schedule
um progress tracking will keep you on
track and remind you if you are getting
uh past due on any of the coursework so
that prompts you to catch up and there
are support tools including a user
Community
um
where you can turn to your fellow
students and a faculty for uh answers to
questions you can also
access our 24x7 help desk so that if you
have any technical issues with the
platform or if you need somebody to do a
quick answer you're on a technical
subject we do have
a 24x7 support
we'll talk about some of the learner
outcomes
oops
so
just want to review with you that you
will be learning alongside other people
from The Working World which means
um
a lot of people come in from it and
services but also all the industries
banking Financial Services software the
automotive industry telecommunications
so as as we said this program applies in
every industry so people from every
industry attend and you the learning
alongside people who may come from
companies like Amazon Tata
Wells Fargo Bank Citibank Oracle IBM
Consulting word world of Accenture
cognizant
Mercedes-Benz
um these are all companies who have
seconded people to this program so
you'll get a chance to network with
peers in different organizations that's
a great way to cross-pollinate
um
we had a number of questions about
how this program helps you in finding
other position a new position so if you
do want to leverage a program like this
to find a new position we will be
providing you a job assist for uh those
of you users who are in India
fortunately it doesn't job assist
doesn't apply outside of India but the
job is a service for India Learners
gives you access to online educational
webinars those actually are available to
everyone worldwide
um the real world projects across
Industries are part of what you do in
the program so that's again also
available to all the participants
worldwide in this program it's the
specific job assist services from IIM
jobs that are specific yeah those
include access to the IIM job portal
these Services last for six months after
you earn your certificate so you will be
able for six months after completing the
program
access the IAM jobs job portal to do uh
confidential searches of their
player Network you'll be able to access
their resume issue and rewrite Services
which give you the opportunity to have
your resume reviewed and Rewritten with
professional help so that it can serve
the dual purpose of
passing through a
automated tracking systems I a I bought
this is how resumes are evaluated these
days and resume has to be in a format
where the AI system can recognize its
content your experience your
skills and then filter you into the rest
of the job search so writing your resume
to filter you in rather than out is a
skill that they'll help you with as well
as keeping it attractive to the human
eye so that
when it lands on hiring manager's desk
or screen
it will still catch their attention and
draw them in
get you to the interview process and
that's another area where this service
helps you because as you know when you
interview for a position you'll have to
go through
phone screen with the HR recruiter or
the um
HR department
you'll have to go through
the technical interviews from your
prospective peers and manager who will
ask you about your ability to do the
work then you'll have to go through
cultural fit interviews that ask about
your fit with the corporate culture your
work ethic your ability to be a teammate
and so these one-on-one interview
sessions allow you to practice each of
those types of interviews with a human
being
yeah coaching on how to pass each one
as I mentioned the webinars which are
done on an ongoing basis by simply learn
these are free no cost available to you
and available to you on a lifelong basis
that cover technical skills
career skills like how to do your job
search
career care and feeding skills soft
skills like how to apply lean principles
in your career for example or a specific
technical subjects in many lessons so
all of this to help keep your skills
sharp over the years
your career
So based on what Professor manage um
said and what I've shared with you are
you
essentially interested in
enrolling in this program
I'll leave this open for about 15
seconds as it's a yes or no question
I'll close the question
five
five four three two one
excuse my weak eyes I have about 88
percent of our audience
who
that they are potentially interested so
I'll share with you
how that process works
now simply learn
is the delivery partner for this program
for IIM indoors we provide the platform
we provide administrative services
and
you email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
to get the process started I am going to
put that into
the
chat box for you so you have that email
address right at your fingertips
between here
well Zoom
bear Zoom is going to shut down and
restart on my end and um
I'll be right back
apologize for that Zoom does that
occasionally
on my side
um again I'm putting into the chat the
email address
all right
so you email us our learning consultant
will then review with you ask for proof
of your educational and work experience
and once we've reviewed your
qualifications we will then send you
letter of admission
and
the next cohort starts
uh classes start in 20 May so you can
get into the induction session on 11
April
you can ask about other cohorts as well
I think there is actually a cohort with
April classes but the induction session
um
may not be happening
between that but definitely the 11 April
induction will get you into the classes
beginning in May
talk about limited seats and the reason
why we say limited seats because this is
a digital program and people obviously
think that
you can put as many people as you want
into a digital program but the truth is
that this is done with live virtual
classes so each batch
uh each cohort has to be limited to
about 25 to 30 people in order for the
instructors and professors to give
sufficient attention to each student
so if this is something that you want to
get started on please do contact us
right away and ask us at simplylearn.net
and we'll get you into the batch of your
choice
here are the fees this program is two
lock 47 800 rupee uh that's inclusive of
taxes
can be financed an equal monthly
installments of
8226 a month
so again reach out to us at ask us
simply learn.net
if you have any questions about that and
or if you want to find out what the
price
is quoted in and what currency is quoted
in in your local country if you're
outside of India
for those of you who answered that you
are interested in this program
how soon
would you like to start are you looking
at the April cohort or are you looking
at
somewhere a little bit further down the
line
I'll close this poll in five four
three
two one
to again
almost two-thirds of our audience are
interested in starting either in the May
classes or possibly June July
that's fantastic and please do email us
immediately and ask us at
simplylearn.net for those of you looking
further down the road uh it's a good
thing to email us now and we'll keep in
touch with you keep you advised to
Future cohorts in the program
and any other requirements that you need
to
satisfy
and
I'm gonna take a few more questions at
this point
before we do this last question so I'm
not going to start this last poll quite
yet
um
we'll stop sharing for a second
and I want to go through to see if there
are any additional questions that I can
help with
um
Professor is not here so I'm not sure
I'll be able to answer everything that's
available here
go through quickly and check to see if I
can answer some of those for you
thank you
mentioned the bonus for the attendees I
will tell you about that right now
so for those of you who attended this
webinar
there is a 15 discount if you tell our
learning consultant about that there
will be a 15 discount this will be
described in the
follow on email as well
so you'll have a
notice of that
and that's your bonus for attending this
webinar and joining and
upcoming
cohort so bonus is not indefinite I do
want to be able to join the May cohort
to take advantage of it
but again details will be in the
follow-on email
can the certificate be used as a
post-graduation certificate
that I would ask the learning
Consultants about its official status
for that purpose this is an executive
certificate so I don't think that
we use the terminology postgraduate
certificate what is the timing schedule
in the week so the classes of programs
are generally either weekends or in the
evenings during the week outside of
working hours
and this is so that working
professionals
you take the course without interfering
with their working hours
um and again we we say you should
dedicate about 10 hours a week
in your overall schedule for this
um
working as an sap consultant with three
years of experience how will this course
help
one of the ways this course will help
you as an sap consultant is
understanding the broader context in
which Erp and supply chain the other
aspects of the sap platform
are used in business so you'll be able
to kind of see the connections between
the the functions that you're
sap platforms
perform in the rest of the business they
support
uh which course is better and demanded
most in the market pgdm or MBA so these
are different um
types of programs I don't know the
answer but you can ask our learning
Consultants about that
and you throw some light on the digital
transformation coverage in this course
uh yes you'd be able to go to the
website for the the course and I'll
share that URL to download the
program syllabus the notion about
digital transformation course is to talk
about how
digital uh technology has made it
possible to do
um
business tasks business processes
management tasks in a new way so we'll
cover examples of that we'll cover
Theory and the
evolution of the technology behind that
and
that's a week
offer other courses that that Focus
entirely on digital transformation
is the course free or not um I think we
covered that
after the program do we get placements
you get assistance with finding a job
but you do not get a guaranteed
placement
is it helpful for political career
um
that's an interesting question because
you have two aspects to your political
career one is
management skills of managing your
campaign efforts managing your office if
you're successful as a uh office holder
so the ability to manage that office is
very important
um
you also need to understand
the concerns of your constituents so if
your political office
covers things that regulate business or
involve business
pardon me this course will help you
understand what the impact of your
decisions as a politician will be on
those constituents
I was a program used useful in the power
sector uh pure in a government utility
you have the same general management
issues but you also have
uh
you need to understand supply chain for
example in great detail both for the
supply chain to keep your network
running but also how you work into the
supply chains of your customers so this
is a
important
uh
will there be assignments that get
graded
there will be assignments in each
program that get assessed not through
letter grade or or percentage grade but
for pass fail and you do need to pass
each of those in order to move from that
course to the next one
you can ask we have a question of
whether this
course like this helps people move up in
management and you can ask our learning
Consultants about examples of people in
their experience
of success after taking the course
okay
how will this help for hardcore sales
professionals with 12 to 15 years of
experience and that's a great question
because it depends on what you're
selling
um if you're in a business to business
field and understanding the business of
your customers going to make you a
better salesperson more successful if
you're looking to manage your own
internal organization possibly move into
management become a sales manager move
into marketing management up in a chain
of command
this will also help you in that
dimension
same thing is true the solution
architect or the
analyst or anybody in a technical or
engineering role
understanding
the management aspects having General
management background will help you
understand your
role and how you can serve your company
more effectively and gain a higher
visibility
okay
and
all right I think the covers from the
questions and answers I'm going to see
if
take a look excuse me in the chat real
quick
I just wanna I apologize if I do not get
to your question
if there's a question in here that I
guessed
from where am I conducting the screening
I happen to be based in California in
the U.S however Professor manage is
based in indoor that's where he was
presenting from
simply learn is a
company based in both
Bangalore in
India as well as in San Francisco
California so we
dual headquartered
International Company
multinational company
okay and I think
I'm going to move on to the last
question and last question I have for
you and the audience
is
oops
shouldn't be sharing that one
pretty sure that
do you need assistance with enrollment
and if you want to receive a proof of
attendance for this session we've just
concluded
answer yes but also if you would like us
to reach out to you to help you with
questions and get you enrolled
also answer yes here
so do you want us to reach out to you
and you want to receive a proof of
attendance for this session
the proof of attendance for this session
of course doesn't carry any weight as a
management certification it just proves
that you came to this webinar
and I'll leave this open for another
three
two one
and about 55 percent of you would like
us to reach out so we will do that after
this webinar
should expect to hear from us in the
next day or so and
those people will also receive the
certificates
a proof of attendance certificates I
should say
with that I want to thank everyone I
would thank Professor manage
for being generous with this time and
knowledge and I want to thank all of you
for being here on this webinar we hope
that we can welcome you into the IIM
indoor simply learned learning community
promised you can use that QR code
access
the
web page but I'm also going to put the
URL into the chat right now
as my voice Fades sorry about that
and
you have that in the chat you have the
URL for our page as well as
our code
and
thank you all
that concludes our webinar